[Musica]
pat modo york
pat ma questo io
questo è un saluto coreano molto diffuso
fino a qualche anno fa letteralmente
significa avete mangiato oggi infatti
dimostra la preoccupazione dei coreani
della propria salute
sappiamo che la corea del sud ha
attraversato una profonda crisi fino a
qualche anno fa però oggi è diventata
una potenza globale nell'ambito
dell'industria della tecnologia per me
nella mia esperienza coreana pato ma
questione del simbolo che le crisi non
solo si possono attraversare ma ci
possono rendere molto più forti però
come si fa sono anni che studio crisi a
livello della società delle
organizzazioni e personali e uno dei
motivi che mi sono appassionato a questo
tema è come si dice a roma sono un po
cercata
ho cambiato otto paesi in 12 anni ho
cambiato tre professioni fine ha dovuto
reinventarmi ricominciare da zero molte
volte e alcune di queste cambiamenti
hanno portato delle crisi
altri cambiamenti invece sono avvenuti
grazie a delle crisi quindi oggi vorrei
parlare di voi di crisi personali di
come attraversale trasformarle ripartire
che cos'è una crisi personale è un
periodo della propria vita dove sentiamo
una profonda energia negativa
all'interno di noi che spesso
riconducibile a un evento a una persona
addirittura una frase nell'ambito di
lavoro la tua performance non è buona
forse licenziato nell'ambito dell'amore
non sono più innamorato di te lasciamoci
e nell'ambito della famiglia o degli
amici o un problema di salute mi devono
operare quindi vorrei chiedere a voi per
è stata la vostra ultima crisi e quale
fatto quell'evento quella frase che l'ha
generata fatto
se ancora se ancora non l'avete trovata
per favore venite voi la prossima per
parlare di come non avere tristi questa
è una delle crisi più significative
della mia vita
quello che vedete il geyser del lago di
ginevra il simbolo della città di
ginevra ma anche il film e lo dico mi
sentivo a ginevra infatti stavo al top
della mia carriera ma mi sentivo che
stavo in caduta libera
nella mia vita personale infatti due
anni prima era riuscito a entrare subito
dopo è laureato in una delle più grandi
multinazionali dei beni di largo consumo
era il mio sogno ideale dopo due anni è
riuscito a farmi trasferire negli head
quarter nella sede europea di questa
società ea ero contentissimo ma dopo
alcune settimane le cose non sono andate
come pensavo
infatti ho avuto molte incomprensioni
con il mio capo che con cui c'erano con
cui ci trovavamo era molto esigente
il marchio per cui lavoravo era in
profonda crisi
quindi dove c'era molta pressione dello
dell'azienda e non era riuscito
inventarmi a ginevra e quindi ho reagito
nell'unico modo che sapevo lavorando più
ore ma le cose non sono migliorate tanto
infatti noi lavorando fiore alcuni sodo
avere meno tempo libero o meno per gli
amici cominciato a mangiare mare dormire
male lavorare male diventava un meno
produttivo e quindi dovevo lavorare più
ore è entrato in circo con questo
circolo vizioso da cui non sapevo come
uscire ero arrivato a pesare 99 kg ea
piangere alcune volte prima di andare al
lavoro tanta l'ansia prima di arrivare a
un evento fortuito drammatico che mi ha
costretto a letto per dieci giorni e che
la prima volta ancora mi ricordo che la
prima volta che non ho aperto l'email
del lavoro
quindici giorni dedicati a me a capire
la mia situazione perché mi sentivo in
questa maniera a capirmi meglio e quando
sono tornato a lavoro incominciato a
parlare con altri colleghi che avevano
lavorato col mio capo che lavoravano per
altri marchi che erano simile al mio che
avevano molta pressione a colleghi holes
anche che avevo chiaro che siano appena
trasferiti a ginevra a chiedere loro
mamma ma voi come fate cosa provate e
con mio stupore le loro delle lui
spostano diversa quelle che mi aspettavo
infatti riconosce uno sì la mia ansia la
macrì fila in difficoltà tra loro
avevano reagito in maniera diversa
vediamo in queste difficoltà o un modo
per imparare di più perché a loro
piaceva il loro lavoro e quindi forse mi
è venuto il dubbio che il problema non
ero non era il contesto in maranello
capo nell'azienda né ginevra
forse forse il problema ero io perché
stavo viaggiando in questa maniera
perché gli altri ragionano in maniera
diversa e quindi incominciato a cercare
quadrare il vero problema quale era la
vera causa e ho fatto questo esercizio
l'esercizio dei valori ho preso una
tabella con tutti i valori e le cose più
importanti della vita è ricominciata a
sottolineare tutte quelle più vicino al
mail ho messo in ordine e questo
esercizio mi ha fatto capire già molte
cose della mia situazione infatti avevo
preso questa carriera anche perchè mi
dava sicurezza economica e sicurezza
sociale
il famoso contratto a tempo
indeterminato che molti italiani cercano
noi sono sempre era anche quello che
faceva piacere alla mia famiglia che mi
avrebbe mi avrebbe dato la sicurezza per
creare la mia famiglia ma il mio vero il
mio valore principale alla passione e
alla domanda era appassionato di quello
che facevo la risposta banalmente erano
una seconda domanda mi ha aiutato ma
voglio fare il lavoro del capo del mio
capo perché come sapete in azienda una
delle motivazioni per lavorare tanto
azione è per essere promossi e come fare
il lavoro del proprio capo per lavorare
ancora di più e diventare il principe il
proprio capo e questo processo se siamo
fortunati dura anni e quindi è una
domanda importante affare dopo questi
anni sarò con tanto di fare il lavoro
del capo del mio capo e la risposta
banalmente erano quindi questi due
esercizi tra gli altri hanno fatto
capire che il vero problema è che non mi
faceva più quella carriera e quindi ho
esplorato 9 alternative ho deciso di
fare un dottorato
mi sono allenato a parigi con la
soddisfazione dei miei e della mia
questo mi ha portato può insegnare al
fiqi e asse gol insigne management e
sono specializzata in gestione delle
crisi
questa invece è una delle mie ultime
crisi 25 marzo 2019 due mesi fa e mi
ricordo bene questa data stavo a letto
guardando il soffitto della camera
in chiara energia negativa ed e
condizionata da una parte sentimentale e
lavorativa professionale anche familiare
e quindi ho fatto l'esercizio che vi ho
detto prima di capire qual è il vero
problema però questo per capire vero
problema ci vogliono alcuni giovani
alcune settimane anche per prendere
delle decisioni
e nel frattempo abbiamo questa energia
negativa non so se vi è mai capitato di
stare a letto di un avere la forza
neanche di andare al lavoro di vedere
degli amici e quindi la domanda è come
gestire questa energia negativa che
proviamo è uno dei motivi per cui
abbiamo è perché la mente alcune volte
alla nostra migliore amica facoltà di
alta la nostra peggiore nemica come
degli studi di psicologia ci dicono
infatti la mente va rivivere quella
persona la frase milioni di volte
cercando forse una soluzione che
comunque ormai inutile e ogni volta che
pensiamo che abbiamo questo pensiero
negativo abbiamo un'altra ondata di
energia negativa dentro di noi e quindi
per gestire questa energia forse
dobbiamo reagire gestire i nostri
pensieri
il discorso silenzioso che abbiamo
all'interno della nostra mente il nostro
percorso mentale e questa è una tecnica
che utilizzato creare il pulsante
d'aiuto cioè selezionare una ristretta
cerchia di amici o familiari che
sappiamo ci posso aiutare per questa
crisi si specifica il pulsante aiuto
quindi è una metafora il pulsante che
possiamo spingere la telefonata che
possiamo fare per nei momenti in cui
siamo particolarmente tristi e parlare
con altra persona ci aiuta a dare una
nuova prospettiva e cambiare il nostro
percorso mentale
questa volta ha fatto una cosa diversa
anche ho utilizzato un percorso un
pulsante di aiuto social virtuale
infatti seguivo da da molti mesi
due gruppi di sviluppo personale e ho
visto che negli ultimi mesi le persone
incominciano a pubblicare richieste di
aiuto e consigli sul libro su coro
suggerimenti per come gestire meglio il
tempo come gestire lo stress come
perdere peso come gestire un collega che
non ci piace o come andare avanti dopo
la fine di una relazione d'amore e
quindi ho deciso anch'io di mettere la
mia domanda ricevuto più di 120 commenti
il fatto che degli stranieri le persone
che non conoscono
adesso in versione del tempo a darmi dei
suggerimenti mi ha fatto sentire meno
solo con alcune di queste persone poi
siamo sentiti in privato ci siamo
aiutati a vicenda a superare questa
crisi e ho voluto anche una serie di
libri di audio e di video che ho
incominciato a leggere ascoltare e
vedere che mi ha aiutato a capire qual è
il vero problema ea superarlo questo
invece una seconda tecnica che
utilizzato la tecnica della tavola dei
desideri la tavola desidera ecco
l'immagine che vedete di fronte il mio
letto quell'immagine è semplicemente
creata con una slide di powerpoint la
divisa nelle quattro aree per me è più
importante la vita per voi possono
essere diverse l'amore le finanze la
carriera e la salute
il passaggio su google interesse
instagram a cercare dell'immagine che di
come volevo sentirmi in quella
particolare alle della vita e quindi
nella parte dell'amore voglio scusarmi
ha delle tre figlie e avere una
relazione con fiducia intimità
complicità e gioiosità nell'ambito delle
finanze raggiungere un equilibrio e la
cosiddetta financial freedom libertà
finanziaria nell'ambito della carriera
ho messo tutte le riviste accademiche
voglio pubblicare i tre anni che voglio
vincere come professori libri che voglio
pubblicare e anche quanti sociali e
qualche info lower fenis social media
voglio avere e nell'anno del saluto
messuti le immagini come vorrei vederli
lì come vorrei sentirmi quando mangio
una volta creata questa tavola dei
desideri lo stampate in diversi formati
e l'omessa name nei posti nei luoghi 2
passato più tempo in camera da letto in
soggiorno in ufficio e l'ho messo anche
cover come cover del mio cellulare e
ogni volta che la mia mente nulla
fregare mandarli nel passato
io cercavo di fregarla e di mandarla
invece nel futuro nei desideri di come
volevo sentirmi non di come mi sentivo
amy focalizzava su tutta questa immagine
e soprattutto sul numero 79 che questa
79 79 un mio obiettivo
chiude il mio peso che da tantissimi
anni
gli ho detto nella m c di ginevra ero
riuscito a
arrivare a 99 kg a sfiorare i 100 però
avevamo perso altissimo peso dato 82 tra
loro ma riuscito arrivare sotto gli 82
kg e nel 25 marzo 2019 dove si fa
pensavo più di 90 chili e quindi mi sono
detto vuoi utilizzare tutta questa
energia negativa per trasformarla in un
mio obiettivo
un obiettivo che va da tantissimi anni e
quindi riuscire a raggiungere 79 kg
entro il 25 maggio cioè oggi e quindi la
bravo ingegnere che ho fatto ho creato
un grafico ho detto quanto devo perdere
di media ogni settimana per raggiungere
questo obiettivo e sono riuscito a
perdere quindi il turno al 20
al 20 aprile pensavo sugli 83 84 kg
quindi hanno perso già tanto però
sappiamo gli ultimi kg sono più
difficili da perdere e poi ho smesso di
pesarmi per un po di tempo e oggi vorrei
condividere con voi questo momento sono
riuscito a raggiungere o meno bio fuel
quindi questo abbiamo bilancio che fai
parata con il come né tv con il peso dei
vestiti
poi possiamo chiedere una persona di
controllare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questi movimenti è fatto un bel viaggio
e questi sono alcuni strumenti
utilizzato per trasformare una crisi il
primo a chiederti qual è il vero
problema perché come nel mio calcio
aveva potuto cambiare corpo cambiare
brand marchio azienda o anche città ma
il problema poi sarebbe tornato perché
il vero problema che non mi piaceva
quella carriera
questo esercizio dei valori può aiutare
a superare a capire il vero problema di
molte crisi e poi cambiare il proprio
percorso mentale quindi creare un
pulsante di aiuto reale o virtuale e
questa tavola dei desideri che mi ha
aiutato tanto a focalizzare a
trasformare l'energia da negativa
positiva perché sapete io so che avrò
altre crisi non può solitaria
probabilmente non possono anche evitare
che voi abbiate però so che si possono
attraversare anzi si possono trasformare
quindi vorrei chiedervi come
trasformerete la prossima prossima crisi
quale sarà il vostro 79 pato questione
[Applauso]